dans les rues d'odessa les habitants se
préparent remplissage de sacs de sable
fabrication de cocktails molotov la
ville du sud du pays tentent d'organiser
sa défense avant l'arrivée des troupes
russes
je suis là pour protéger ma ville jade
en cuisinant en remplissant les sacs de
sable et en nettoyant ma maison est là
bas et il faut la défendre nous avons
été élevé comme ça
tous le savent leur ville située sur les
bords de la mer noire est un point
stratégique pour les forces russes qui
souhaite ainsi isoler complètement les
ukrainiens de leur façade maritime
il n'y a pas de combat odessa
aujourd'hui
mais les navires militaires russes
croiser près d'odessa dans la mer noire
on suppose que l'ennemi s'organise c'est
ce que nous pensons
l'ennemi prépare une opération terrestre
sur notre ville
au dessin est en effet fragilisé par sa
situation géographique
l'assaut peut venir de la mer d'une
attaque terrestre depuis carson à l'est
mais aussi du ciel on est il se prépare
à bombarder odessa au dessin les russes
se sont depuis toujours vendu à odessa
ils ont toujours été accueillie avec
hospitalité avec sincérité et à présent
ils envoient des bombes contre desa
l'artillerie contre des ca des roquettes
contre des ça ce sera un crime de guerre
ce sera un crime historique
le maire de la ville insiste ainsi sur
l'importance de la création d'une zone
d'exclusion aérienne pour protéger la
population
une demande d'ores et déjà rejetée par
l'otan